[Music]
Christian you're on the air
yes dr. wall of good afternoon thank you
for speaking with me how can I help you
yes sir well first things first I I
don't know I haven't been properly
diagnosed with this but I've been
dealing with this and I've read a lot
about Lyme disease I got bit by a bug in
2012 I'm 33 years old and I feel like
I'm 93 I have since then about two years
after me getting bit
I've been attributing a lot of symptoms
tingling sensations brain fog tune it
tinnitus in the ears
memory loss very malaise feeling like
I'm here what about okay let me ask you
a couple quick questions here cuz we
only have a moment
yes sir um do you have any skin problems
any dry skin eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis no but I have chronic
allergies and sinusitis
okay and then what about any respiratory
problems any asthma allergies any asthma
in there or chronic bronchitis I have
chronic wheezing at times it comes and
it goes
mm-hmm okay wheezing that could be
diagnosed he went to a respiratory
clinic they might diagnose you with a
husband PM wheezing okay and let's see
here mm-hmm give any brothers and
sisters yes I do I have an older brother
younger sister okay Danny didn't have
any asthma bronchitis or skin problems
or bowel pom constipation diarrhea
my brother has asthma okay all right
what do you wait I am a hundred and
seventy-five and actually gain weight
within a year and a half I'm 13 I'm five
nine five nine and you're 33 years old
okay yes I'm sure what's Christian's
basic problem he's got a gluten
intolerance and that way you gains
weight because you can you can't absorb
nutrients but you can absorb sugar
exactly absorb
calories are not nutrients exactly right
when you have six or eight diseases like
you have and of course Lyme disease and
you say you've had it for two or three
years Lyme disease is easily killable
with antibiotics in two weeks like
syphilis is easily killable and with
antibiotics in two weeks the odds are
you have a gluten intolerance here and
so what would you give this guy at 175
pounds I give him two healthy brain and
heart packs okay very good and he's got
tonight's got out she posted a skull
would you add to the to Tony Bennett
artifacts okay two large bombs gluco gel
15 a day if I'm at breakfast lunch and
dinner and what would you do for energy
what would you give him is a sort of
energy support oh I take it as the
rebound everyday rebound okay very good
you can get it in cans you can get it in
sticks or you can get it in the canister
and then absolutely none of the bands
whose no fried foods no processed meats
no oils of gluten or sugar and the
gluten wheat brother out and oats is
very very important here because it
allow your intestines to heal is improve
the absorption of nutrients and let's
get it heavy give us a call every two
weeks and let us know how all these
various things are going when you take
these nutritional programs they will
support maintenance repair of all these
tissues the rebound will give you the
energy there's no gluten in there and
stay away from all the bad stuff the
fried foods process means also gluten I
would also stay away from sugar which
can contribute to memory problems with
Korsakov syndromes it could contribute
to exhaustion kind of as a reactive
hypoglycemia kind of thing so I stay
away from juices and fruit that's a nice
saying things like Gatorade has two
minerals already has six minerals
rebound Arts Board shrink has 100
nutrients okay including 78 minerals so
shower hit the nail on the head get an
A+ on this one and let's see here
give us a call every couple of weeks to
do it Christian because I don't think he
had Lyme disease
I think char's exactly right he got
gluten intolerance it's not unusual to
see little bits and pieces of this but
you need to warn your mom if she's still
alive your brother your sister
and all your sisters children need to be
gluten-free will add 25 to 50 healthy
years of life
[Music]